[Musique]
6 il faut bien qu'elle hommes des
enfants matin tiens t'as vu ton meilleur
pote mourir maintenant tu te sens
coupable mais en fait 10 pour rien un
service à me demander
j'accepte attend d'abord de savoir ce
que c'est pas la bonne cible
j'ai besoin de toi pour faire tomber un
des deux méthodes c'est chef d'un gang
de bikers appli loup ici c'est chez moi
maintenant doit faire tirer deux ans que
je cherchais recouvre t l'un des nôtres
c'est pour toi
oui c'est parce que tu as tué mon cri un
même toit
on a perdu un frère
et à nous de le venger
aurait pu étudier brouillard
c'est pas ce qui
même sans retour c'est pour quitter près
là cet ensemble